hello and welcome to PlayStation granade
video games force us to play for
countless hours completing every aspect
of the story before we are eventually
rewarded with the final ending cinematic
it's the accumulation of days weeks and
sometimes even months of hard work
ignoring family commitments work and
school to achieve our goals but in some
games it's possible to unlock a surprise
shortcut ending negating all our hard
work here's eight quick endings you can
achieve in no time at all of course be
warned there will be spoilers for the
following titles Metal Gear Solid 5 may
look like it's all about box sledging
and for turning sheep but it had a
deeper meaning about nuclear weapons and
war the online portion of mgs 5 allowed
players to create their own base of
operations and attack other players for
resources Intel and those nuclear
warheads but on the 5th of February 2018
a cutscene triggered on the PC version
of mgs 5 showcasing the real secret
ending of the game back home on mother
base snake and his crew hear the news
that the last warhead in the game has
been deactivated and the world is now
finally ready for peace Milla gives a
rousing speech about the importance of
nuclear disarmament and the player is
left with a real sense of accomplishment
and a profound realization of their
actions but then the games publisher
Konami told us the cutscene was
activated accidentally after hack has
introduced so many nukes into the game
it broke the system completely on the
plus side we probably saved hundreds of
years of playing mgs 5 obtaining this
ending so should we thank the new
cockers or not tough choice the last
nukes been decommissioned it's over
I thought this day would never come back
right bar introduced a shortcut ending
which probably gave us the most
satisfying ending as pagan min became
the father figure we always wanted
we all loved it so much that far cry 5
was certain to have another super quick
ending to unlock and it was actually
found before the game released to set
the scene far cry 5 follows the downfall
of cult leader Father Joseph seed and
his fanatical worshippers but in the
opening scene it's possible to change
that outcome when sent him to arrest
father Joseph countless people died in a
helicopter incident by the way did you
see the guy jumping into the blades what
a way to go instead we can decide not to
arrest father Joseph and simply stand
around and do nothing until this happens
we're leaving rook what the [ __ ] are you
doing what are you doing what the [ __ ]
are you doing
sure get back there listen you put those
cuffs on him none of us get out of here
alive I will have you all arrested so
busy
well that was anticlimactic bring back
pagan min I miss you you sir are a
gentle oh here's one which requires so
little effort it's referenced as the
coward's ending in the Stanley parable
it's a first-person interactive story
which pokes fun at video game narrative
tropes the narrator tells the player
what to do but the player has enough
agency to obey or ignore the narrator's
voice coming to a staircase Stanley
walked upstairs to his boss's office
with around 20 possible endings which
regularly break the fourth wall one can
be unlocked almost immediately
Stanley he can simply close the door to
his office but Stanley's simply couldn't
handle the pressure what if he had to
make a decision what if a crucial
outcome fell under his responsibility he
had never been trained for that no this
couldn't go any way except badly the
thing to do now Stanley thought to
himself is to wait nothing will hurt me
nothing will break me in here I can be
happy forever I will be happy sternly
waited hours passed then days had years
gone by he no longer had the ability to
tell but the one thing he knew for sure
beyond any doubt was that if he waited
long enough the answers would come
eventually someday they would arrive
soon very soon now this will end he will
be spoken to he will be told what to do
now it's just a little bit closer
now it's even closer here it comes
yeah that's it literally it just cuts to
black and it's done to get the other
dozen or so endings you'll need to put
in a little bit more effort agent Kidman
are we awake to get the evil within
surprise shortcut ending you'll need the
consequence DLC and you'll have to play
the first four chapters I know I know
that's not a shortcut ending well it
does cut out the final boss battle so
it's sort of you're worthy of the list
the evil within tells us the story of
Detective Sebastian Castellanos I'm so
sorry if I'm butchering that Detective
Sebastian Castellanos and his co-workers
who investigate a gruesome murder inside
the mental hospital I'm sure you've
guessed already it's a horror title the
story slowly reveals ruvik a chap who
created a machine to control reality and
after his demise his brain was needed to
keep the machine functioning and there's
me thinking it was just a nice
centerpiece you know to start
conversations in the original game we
destroy the brain in the final encounter
which ends the nightmare so with this
info in mind no pun intended the first
time we see rubik's machine again in the
dlc we run straight over there and shoot
to the brain how easy was that now
that's how to take out an end box but
wait up I don't think the game is going
to let us get away with that
goddamnit sadly time is reversed and we
still have to finish the game the old
legitimate waste so we did see the
credits but maybe that wasn't a shortcut
ending before Epic Games began printing
their own money
thanks to fortnight battle royale they
developed many video games back in 2009
Shadow Complex released on the Xbox it
was a 2.5 D running a gun platform
shooter which sets up the whole
adventure with the first date of Claire
and Jason when Claire is kidnapped our
hero Jason days no not that Jason no not
that Jason either her hero Jason rescues
Claire because that's what video games
teach us to do
valor loyalty sacrifice but Shadow
Complex has another solution simply walk
back to our Jeep and go find another
lady to hit on
plenty of fish in the city
I'll always wonder what happened to
glass this is truly an unjust in Persona
five is yet another game with countless
ending cinematics to unlock one of which
allows you to end the game before it
even begins during the User Agreement
it's possible to disagree with the
general understanding of the word
fiction and the narrator well he quickly
shuts you down I see everything that
happens from here on in is real is that
your cognition of this then
unfortunately I cannot allow you to
partake of this game I must ask that you
leave persona 5 is a narrative heavy RPG
which can leech hundreds of hours away
from your life and depicts an entire
year of life in a modern-day Tokyo
school I mean the game is so deep you
can even get a part-time job there's a
few ways to get early endings in the
game with my favorite being the sellout
ending which can see the game end in
November and cut off the final four
months of the story during an
interrogation scene it's possible to
give up the identity of all your friends
to save your worthless skin but of
course the game doesn't stand for that
and send in a hitman to make you regret
grassing up all your mates for the rest
of your sorry life what are you
[Music]
[Music]
have you finally pieced it all together
[Music]
case closed
this is how your justice ends disloyalty
will not be tolerated here this place is
dangerous I like it
you're expecting a kiss speaking of
disloyalty let's delve into superhero
law in Batman Arkham City the Catwoman
dlc she embraces her cat-burglar roots
and cracks Harvey Dent safe to steal
precious Intel after a brief little
rough and tumble Selina Kyle gets the
loot she's been looking for but during
her escape she sees that Batman is in
need of help at this point we have a
dilemma you can do it just walk right
out of here and leave him it's easy
you'll never forgive yourself Selina
save Batman then get out of here it's
not like he'll die it's Batman right go
on
just leave Batman to die ease these the
main problem around Gotham anyway screw
him after walking away the credits roll
but just as we ponder our choices the
Oracle tells us what happened without us
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
while the heck just as we escaped we are
thrown back and forced to help Batman
out of this predicament stupid bloody
but dead always needing saving fine fine
we'll save Batman figured you could use
my help
have you ever played dying light you
should it's bloody great it's another
game where it's easy to be sidetracked
you to the park oi used open world and
the freakishly satisfying melee combat
against the undead hordes there's even a
shock good ending in the following the
expansion pack which allows you to
ignore a bulk of the game but requires a
little exploration to achieve first we
need three items scattered around the
open-world offshore on the east side of
the map deep underwater are a set of
nuclear codes to grab a military
transport key can be found in a
warehouse and finally at the base of the
dam is a dead body with a military
activation code to grab with all these
three items in hand we must now locate
the military truck on the highway
next we can do the right thing and set
off a nuclear warhead you know the
things that Metal Gear Solid 5 told us
never to use well maybe we should keep
one or two around just in case you know
we have a post-apocalyptic wasteland -
this price
Wow that's the depressing end to the
video hmm so there we have it seven
super secret shortcut endings to video
games which can cut hours off your play
time have I missed any I'm sure I have
please let me know your thoughts in the
comments and I'll make a follow-up video
I'm Adam from Playstation grenades and
if you made it to the end of the video
you're a freaking legend I salute you
it's been a pleasure I'll see you next
time
[Music]